people who like the way I look at things
is how I process what she's saying is
you notice like she keeps on mentioning
this Alleyway kind of scenario you think
it's kind of interesting that in the
media when people kind of portray if
it's normally in the alleyway great oh
great portray this kind of stuff it's
normally in the alleyway anyway
the majority the majority of it it's
programmed isn't it it's scary people
watch these same videos especially the
feminists they watch these same videos
they get these same narratives and then
in real life they act like they live in
Alleyways and that this is like a
scenario that actually happens by ease
yeah but the thing is your Mo you're
most likely to get graped not in an
Alleyway by somebody that you know of
course yeah your partner right so what
so why the anyway analogy is what is
what you're saying Alleyways at night
it's because she I think she lives where
she lives
you're 32. and yeah so you can't pick
somewhere that's not down in Alleyway is
there not a cost of living crisis or do
you honestly think it's that easy to
pick up a move you could move into a
cheaper area outside of the city there's
always Solutions
okay you're telling me the only houses
that you could live in are down dark
alleyways
in all of wherever you live in whatever
town you live in the only places that
you could pick to live you have to go
down dark alleyways
what is this wow does that make any
sense it doesn't that's yeah what do you
mean so every time as a woman we buy a
house we've got to scope the area to
check if that's anyway yeah if I live
but why don't men just stop talking okay
if I I no I live I I live here there's
no there's no guy that lives here and
one of my requirements when looking at
apartments was I need a front desk
person because I I want security because
I don't want to be in a dangerous
situation
um sorry I'll put off saying it because
I'd imagine I'm in Council so I didn't
ever say where I got but do you know you
know what you just said which is very
interesting he said why don't guys stop
stalking yeah right
you know Society doesn't you know yeah
exactly you know please
people get told not to do things all the
time we get told not to steal we get
told not to murder and we get told not
to group we get tons to a lot of things
people still do it so because we know
people still do it right now it's time
for you as a person to take to take it
on yourself to say I know people do this
let me put myself in a position where
I'm mostly least likely to have that
affect me because people out there still
like I've got a car should I have a car
without an alarm and a mobilizer no no
but I can say people shouldn't steal
cars of course I should say people
should steal cars but they do so I've
now got to protect myself from the
people that do still cost so this is one
of the things about um self-agency and
being like accountability for yourself
and I'm not saying that people should
not or people should be grapes and
people should be essayed but I'm saying
there are situations in their scenarios
that Pearl was saying that you can put
yourself in or not put yourself into to
make that more likely to happen to us so
do you do anything to prevent like of
course I switch up the way I walk home
there's so to walk back into my estate
there's two Alleyways or it would be
like a 45 minute walk around the whole
way okay I switch on my routine every
time I walk I I've been watching crime
documentaries from along a young age no
no no but that's the truth that's the
truth though isn't it it's just what is
is true but you know so everything goes
of course but it's not just it's not
just women being killed by men but the
thing is that I find when I watch these
documentaries where women are are being
killed by men is that there was numerous
numerous numerous numerous chances to
nip in the bud or put him away for life
before it got to the chance he killed
someone can I ask you something that's
literally with like every murder every
every city yeah of course come on so so
why is that like just just why we were
talking about that that's the same with
every crime it should be the same with
every crime you should get you should
get a sentence that reflects the crime
and you shouldn't be allowed to go out
and recommit I think I was going to ask
you something you said you watch a lot
of um crime crime stuff I kind of feel
like
you're kind of feeding into it you're
feeding into the trauma you're feeling
into the paranoia instead of taking
accountability okay there's certain
things you you have a choice on what
you're putting into your mm-hmm yeah of
course you also have a choice of where
you walk and where you go I've also got
you know female friends who take
precautions you know they send their
live location they avoid certain places
they stay on the phone to me or they
they just don't go home at a certain
time I do understand that not everybody
has the same form of a you know
advantages or whatever but there are
things that you can do to adapt to this
situation and when I look at you and I
listen to you like I keep on saying this
is all a case of you not riding or you
know broadening your horizons in terms
of understanding we all know that people
do bad things in different situations
but what are you doing to prevent that
and protect yourself without having a
hatred for that one particular thing
thank you and like do you think that's
like this is the reason why I'm having
this come conversation the reason when
we're doing this in a great area because
I think that that's psychology that you
have is becoming more and more prevalent
men are just being seen as automatic
Predators but they're just being seen as
automatic bad guy and it's like not a
good one no but there's a reason we need
men though
I never said we didn't know I'm not
saying what I'm saying Society needs men
so to paint men in a bad light
consistently and continuously what it's
going to do to men is at some point when
they're gonna be like oh well if you see
us as such bad people you know what you
look do it yourself good men build the
world for us and you're [ __ ] on them
as a thank you right do you think can I
ask you a question do you look around
the world as like in terms of wars that
are happening the abortion riots that
have been taken away from women that
over in Afghanistan with with their
girls not allowed to go to schools and
they're being married off do you
honestly think the world is a nice place
to live right now I think that the world
is we have the lowest poverty rate ever
in human history but that doesn't in the
West in the west we are not oppressed at
all yeah at all as women who we have
every single right you could possibly
want
the thing is I said do you think the
word is best is it good yeah I think
it's better than it was 500 years ago of
course but I still I mean it's good yeah
but it's better than it was 500 years
ago 40 years ago what do you say I think
the world is a great place to live I
don't understand that question do you
think the world is a good place because
oh because apparel said there are men
created this world for us and I'm seeing
[ __ ] oh oh so your question was the
world sucks I'm saying
you have more safety than ever than
women ever did like living being a
single woman is a privilege yeah like
you historically could not do that
because you would need to be protected
from other men or other Predators right
yeah and so men built this world where
they're the police officers or the
firemen they build the buildings or the
engineers they're the plumbers they're
the electricians 95 Plus
and as a thank you you call them all
predators again you could not live the
way you live without without men because
if you call the police
it's gonna be a man most of the time you
you want a woman turning up when you're
in trouble
um I I
um I don't have any faith in the police
no I wouldn't call them and this it was
like
desperate like I genuinely thought my
life was going to end it was in seconds
well it depends situational
um I don't know someone's breaking into
your house
what are you doing oh I suppose in those
cases but when it is
life is in danger who are you calling I
don't trust them okay who who are you
calling I'll have to call them but I
don't trust them it doesn't seem like
you trust many people
um I don't see why people do if I'm
honest I don't look around and see much
not joy in the world there's plenty of
joy in the world there is I'm not going
to see her and say there isn't however
there's there's a massive problem when
it comes to certain things classes and
racism misogyny homophobia they they're
all interlinked they're all [ __ ]
I don't think they're all problems I
think I think you go on Tick Tock and
you watch videos no I've got a brain and
I open my eyes complaining about the
same things so for example homophobia
homosexual people are like two percent
of the population
okay so what does that mean that they
don't need to protect you so the idea
that this is like some massive problem
is like what it don't matter just I'm
the first to start off they're literally
like a minority of a minority that's
true and then on top of that gay men
like they're all predators as well not
they're one of my best Mates is gay
but he he's why would he be a predatory
yeah no I understand what you're saying
back to what other men but I'm talking
I'm talking about that as as a woman do
you see what I mean like in terms of
again I can't say all men but this is
the thing that I think I think I wish I
would could rewind myself because I
would love to know what you was coming
up with now because I've I've explained
myself numerous times what I should have
said to your question when you said do I
see men as Predators what I should have
said is situational okay so maybe then
then it's a different thing so in a
certain situations I I would see all men
as a predator 100 yes in certain
situations I would see it
situations
I think more women alone on the tube
alone on the bus I don't think I think
more women are predators than men I do I
do Street interviews at night and I'm
much more afraid of getting attacked by
a woman than a man because if anything
if I'm attacked by a dude another dude
will come help me I I the only time I've
ever been scared of getting like punched
or had someone attack me it was a woman
that's fair that's your experience mine
would be a man so there would gonna come
from different angles aren't we
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible